[Música]
y analizamos el último informe de crisis
group que rastrea los conflictos
alrededor de todo el mundo para así
ayudar a los responsables de la toma de
decisiones es decir los gobiernos
ejecutivos de todo el mundo a prevenir
la violencia también identificando
tendencias y alertando sobre los riesgos
de escalada y también las oportunidades
para promover la paz tan difícil de
lograr en yemen los útiles se podrían
atacar a sitiar la ciudad de marib y las
fuerzas rivales en libia podrían
movilizarse alrededor de las elecciones
del 24 de diciembre en medio de una
falta de consenso sobre el marco
electoral y las disputas sobre la
elegibilidad de algunos candidatos
presidenciales y además la concentración
militar de rusia a lo largo de la
frontera con ucrania aumentó esto las
preocupaciones nacionales e
internacionales sobre una posible
invasión y un nuevo conflicto armado en
esa región pero no sólo las alertas de
price scrub se centran en yemen libia
rusia con ucrania y para ello quiero
saludar en este momento a renata segura
ya sub directora para américa latina del
international crisis group gracias
serenata por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 hablemos
del informe general en que se basan
ustedes para realizar este informe para
de alguna manera puedes decir cuáles van
a ser estos conflictos que se pueden
desarrollar en el año 2022 y que están
como en un punto de ebullición a punto
de estallar no renata sí cuales contiene
oficinas en todos los países que
cubrimos en todas las regiones y tenemos
analistas en el campo son lo que
caracteriza el trabajo de crisis club
tenemos personas que están en los
lugares del conflicto que están
constantemente en contacto con tanto los
gobiernos como las fuerzas rebeldes
donde hay y tienen digamos el dedo en el
pulso sobre lo que está pasando en cada
uno de estos países entonces como
organización nosotros hacemos cada mes
este informe que ustedes están
resaltando hoy que se llama crisis watch
en el que tenemos 4
hacemos aquellos conflictos que están en
más riesgo como los tres que tú acabas
de mencionar para este mes tenemos otros
países que calificamos como una
situación deteriorada
algunos lugares donde quizás la
situación ha mejorado un poco o aquellos
donde hay resolución del conflicto a la
vista lamentablemente para el próximo
mes no estamos viendo ninguna resolución
del conflicto ni una situación mejorada
solamente estamos viendo lugares donde
las cosas están un poco peor o como tú
bien dices ucrania yemen y libia donde
estamos muy preocupados que puede haber
una explosión de violencia en el corto
plazo renata ya hablamos de esos países
un poco lejanos para nosotros para
nuestro continente y para nuestra región
ahora vamos a enfocarnos en américa
latina y el caribe vamos a hablar de
colombia la violencia incluso de cara a
estas elecciones presidenciales 2022 que
resaltan en este territorio colombiano
si estamos viendo que las posibilidades
de que las elecciones del año entrante y
lamentablemente no sean tan pacíficas
como las que ocurrieron en la última vez
cuando después del proceso de paz las
farc habían se habían desmovilizado
hacia poco y fueron los las elecciones
más pacíficas de la historia de colombia
en los últimos 50 años estamos
particularmente preocupados en este mes
por los procesos de desplazamiento y
confinamiento que se han dado sobre todo
en la costa del pacífico incluyendo
particularmente a buenaventura y a
nariño en estos lugares hay combates
entre el ejército y las fuerzas
disidentes las que así se llaman
disidencias de las farc pero también hay
combates con algunos grupos
paramilitares tales como el clan del
golfo en choco
también se ven cauca esta es una lucha
por control del territorio
sobre todo en aquellos lugares donde hay
economías ilícitas que se ha venido
incrementando mes a mes y estamos muy
preocupados que es algo que pueda
explotar de manera más sistemática antes
de las elecciones de marzo y
naturalmente la segunda vuelta si
llegaba el 1 así es renato entonces
ahora hablemos de la vecina venezuela
qué pasa en ese territorio y qué podría
pasar cuál es la preocupación
bueno como ustedes bien saben venezuela
tuvo sus elecciones hace el mes pasado
es la primera vez que la oposición
participa en esta nueva etapa después de
que juan guaidó se haya nombrado como
presidente interino en las elecciones se
dieron de manera relativamente pacífica
entonces en términos de violencia no es
algo que nos preocupó mucho aunque hubo
algunos casos en el departamento de zuia
donde si hubo violencia pero como
seguramente ustedes bien saben las
elecciones de marina van a ser repetidas
el año entrante porque el candidato de
la oposición que venía ganando fue
descalificado a posteriori eso puede ser
un contexto preocupante en dependiendo
de cómo se vean las elecciones y
naturalmente el deterioro de la
situación de seguridad a la crisis
económica que hay en venezuela los
altísimos números de inmigración y la
decisión de la corte penal internacional
de abrir una investigación en dicho país
pues son todos factores que pueden
llevar aún más estabilización o quizás
algo de violencia naturalmente estamos
todos muy pendientes sobre la decisión
del gobierno de maduro de regresar a la
mesa de negociaciones en mexico si lo
hace o no esta mesa fue levantada
después de que álex a un colaborador
cercano del presidente fuera extraditado
de cabo verde a eeuu
crisis look ha enfatizado durante muchos
años que la resolución negociada es la
única posibilidad de salir de la crisis
en venezolana y esperamos que todos los
actores vuelvan a la mesa en mexico con
la mayor prontitud posible
rápidamente renata nos queda escasamente
un minuto para finalizar no quiero dejar
de pasar lo que ocurre en haití un país
tan golpeado el asesinato del presidente
el terremoto que va a pasar en esta en
este país
haití es quizás el país más preocupante
en la región en este momento hay dos
opciones en la mesa está el presidente
ayer el perdón del primer ministro ariel
henry que fue un el ministro encargado
después de la necesidad todo el
presidente boris que ya está tratando
crear un gobierno de coalición con
varios gobiernos sin embargo hay una
propuesta alternativa que viene de parte
de la sociedad civil que se ha
organizado en lo que se llama el montana
acuerdo y ellos están proponiendo un
gobierno de transición que sea colegiado
y elegido por varios sectores
representativos de la sociedad civil
haitiana estas dos alternativas si no
llegara a haber un consenso si no
llegara a haber una propuesta conjunta
podría generar grandes estabilidad
porque mucha gente ve el gobierno de
henri como no legítimo hay que aunar a
esto los altos casos de kobe no
obviamente la crisis económica y la
crisis humanitaria generada por el
terremoto es realmente una situación muy
muy preocupante